welcome back to unsensed my next guest
has been a GP with the NHS for 25 years
working as a mentor for recently
qualified doctors at his surgery in Haro
Northwest London Dr wahed azif Shader
has another less wholesome identity as
leader of an is Islam Islamic extremist
Group which was recently caught on
camera calling for Jihad at an
anti-israel
demonstration what is the solution to
liberate people in the concentration
camp of palestin what is the solution
sh also known as Abdul wahed joins me
now welcome to thank you for coming in
today um you've come from your work as a
NHS GP yeah um let me first just ask you
your reaction to the clip we just played
these are members of your organization
and they're a loud chance of of jihad on
the Streets of London do you think
that's
acceptable um that demonstration was a
very carefully planned demonstration
where the placards the banners the
speeches from the platform were calling
for a military intervention of official
armies of Muslim countries to rescue the
people of Gaza with a situation of a
civilian population of 2 million who are
being massacred and slaughtered anywhere
else in the world you would find it a
completely straightforward thing for
people calling for military intervention
but they weren't calling they weren't
chanting we want military intervention
they were chanting Jihad so so my
question for you is simply do you
support the chanting of jihad the
chanting of jihad by somebody that
unscripted or quite a few people there
actually actually no it's about two
people so you would you would condemn
that of course I wouldn't condemn that
you wouldn't no because Jihad in that
context is to they as they understood it
and they were chanting is for the
official armies of Muslim countries to
enter and intervene we in a situation
now appears where
1% of the population of Gaza has been
killed in the space of two months 1% of
the children of Gaza have been killed
anywhere else in the world you yourself
called for military intervention in
Ukraine by NATO with probably less legal
and moral cause than there is in Gaza
when we stand oh absolutely because do
you think the When Vladimir Putin
illegally invaded Ukraine the moral
right of ukrainians to respond is
somehow equivalent to the moral right of
people in Palestine after October the
7th to do the same is that what you're
saying I'm saying that the people of
Ukraine have actually one of the most
powerful armies in the region it doesn't
change the fact they were legally
invaded does it the people of Gaza have
nobody helping them well they they have
a mass they have a ter they have nobody
helping hang on hang on they have a
terrorist organization called aass have
nobody helping them they got 30,000
terrorists who committed on October the
7th act Terris they have lined up
against them the murderous this Defense
Force they have lined up against them
the United States who this week today in
the Washington Post it was said that the
white phosphorus that's being used by
the IDF is supplied by them they have
lined up against them the Britain and
the EU they have lined up against them
the Arab rulers in the region who carry
on their trade cooperations listen as
I've made clear doctor I I think a lot
of the response from Israel particularly
right now I would deem to be testing
everyone's sense of what is
proportionate right there's no question
I do not subscribe to the view it's
genocide that is the understatement of
the Cent possibly but I think they have
a I think they have a right to defend
themselves against a terror group who
have gone on record in the last two
weeks as saying they want to do what
happened oer again again children of
understand it's it's horrific it's
horrific it's beyond it's beyond
horrific because literally what we are
watching what we are watching on our
phones on our laptops on our TVs is is
an extension of what's been happening
since 194 let me play you your reaction
all right I understand let me play you
after October the 7th a few days later
you took part in a talk on YouTube and
you said
this Brave mujah they gave the enemy a
punch on the nose all right and and it's
a very welcome punch on the
nose how can you categorize a terrorist
attack in which
1,200 mostly innocent civilian people
were brutally attacked raped tortured
beheaded and murdered how can you a
British NHS doctor or NHS doctor in
Britain how can you say that's a welcome
punch on my
nose will you let me answer fully yes I
will be frank I'll be as concise as I
can be but if you give me the courtesy
of letting me answer answer fully
okay I will defend the right of the
Palestinians to to resist an occupation
when you look at that that's not
resistance that's terrorism when you
look at what happened and the 7th of
October as if that is the day that
everything started I didn't say that you
didn't say that but when people look at
that do you think what happened that day
was a terrorist attack when people look
do do you know the the word terrorism
has become so uh uh politicized actually
not really the word the word terrorism
sympathetic to the of Palestinian civan
which I am by the way and I've expressed
many times what you can't do is be
weasly mou about what happened October I
asked you to let
a you to finish but you're equivocating
about it being a terror I'm not
equivocating and I will explain why okay
the the the word terrorism by the way in
India last last month we don't talk
about India talk about happen the word
terrorism in India people who supported
the Australian cricket team have been
arrested under terrorist offenses in the
West Bank people who are revealing have
been told if you reveal what happened in
the prisons you will be arrested on
terrorist do you think what happened
October the 7th a terror ATT it's a
resist it's a resistance not a terror
attack appears if if and it's if NHS GP
if I'm asking you to let me finish if
right our our Islamic standard in
conflict in Warfare our Prophet peace be
upon Him sah alai wasallam he said you
can't kill children you can't kill women
you can't kill the Elder you can't
mutilate
if anybody did that if what do you mean
if I say if because they literally
broadcast it on their own streaming
platforms and well I tell you what a lot
of us saw broadcast it merrily to the
world here's here's us doing these
terrible things what do you mean if what
many of us saw on that day were videos
coming out showing people saying we will
not harm women we will not harm children
do me a favor no no that's what doctor
I'm saying that I'm saying that
resistance is a right in Islam it's a
right in intern national law it's even a
right that Churchill said in his history
of the English speaking peoples that is
he actually he actually wrote in that
book it is a primary right of men to
kill and die for the land they live in
you literally just read me a description
of what people who follow Islam are not
supposed to do and Hamas did all of
those things but your response is to say
well hang on I've seen videos of them
saying we don't want to do that stuff no
I yes I find that pretty offensive
doctor I find we all know they did it
they boed to the world with their own
videos what they were doing I find it
amazing that respected journalists like
yourself have seem to have suspended
their critical fac I'm believing what
Hamas wanted me to see well you're
believing what you saw what Hamas
themselves broadcast to the world
because they wanted to take great Glee
in what they've done let me there's no
there's no ambiguity about it I asked
you to let me finish and I'm going to
you got to answer questions answer the
question let's agree on a principle if
atrocities were committed right I will
never condone them right I will say that
so do you condemn what happened on
October the 7th if atrocities are
committed you know who's respons know
they were who's responsible for it then
so you don't condemn it okay who is
responsible the Jews bought it on
themselves actually I would say more
more than that I would say the powers
that believe that Israel should be a
colony for themselves in the Middle East
they are the ones responsible struggling
I've got to be honest with you I'm
really struggling that a national a
British National Health Service doctor
of 25 years a man who's supposed to be
seeing patients all day every day and
putting them right is incapable of
saying what happened when it was
literally broadcast to the World by a
terror group nor do you think they're
terrorists you think it's resistance you
seem to want to go way to justify it you
don't even believe what they showed us
with their with their own technology and
I'm I'm just curious do you think any of
this is compatible with you being a
doctor in the National Health Service
you don't have to be a doctor do your
patients know that you believe these
things you don't have to be a doctor
to care for the lives of two million
people in Gaza you don't have to be I'm
concerned about whether your patients
here in this country were Hamas are a
prescribed to terrorist organization and
I've with they're listening to me do
these do these patients know your VI I
have said to you do they know your views
I don't to my patients about my views in
a 10-minute confrontation do I nobody
does that it's just a foolish question
isn't it that's a foolish question yeah
nobody talks to why do you use a
different name for I use my name well
you don't you have two names one the
leader of the group Abdul wahed is a
name that family friends and other
people call me actually even some people
that's not the name you use at work even
some people at work and ABD and sha is
my legal name which people use in other
forums that's not a very unusual in May
2023 a no I have to no I'm going to ask
you question you did not give me the
courtesy why because your answers were
so outrageous you censor that's your
answer no no I don't censor the person
doing the censoring is you respect who
wants me to try and understand and
believe that what H Mas sodas boasted
about with their own technology
broadcasting it to the world was not
what we saw you that's called censorship
that is actually the purest
personification of censoring the truth
I've ever encountered Mark regev onto
the show yeah and you you question him
lightweight questioning allbe it
lightweight questioning about the
atrocities that have happen you think
it's I give you I actually ask you
difficult question actually you don't
you don't ask difficult questions yeah
you completely accept you listen sit
there and listen to the most ridiculous
explanations unlike you and your answers
you mean well you don't give me the
chance to say that no I've heard your
answers no you didn't oh I have I have
you didn't you don't well okay let's do
a little quick you're telling you're
telling the answer let's do a little
quick far recap do you think Hamas are a
terror group I believe it's a resistance
organization do you think what they did
in October 7th was a terror attack I
believe that if civilians got killed on
that day it is it is apping it is apping
you're a doctor man is apping you're a
doctor in also believe also believe 1200
people got massacred and 1% of the
population I can share your concerns
about what's happened you know you don't
oh no I do no I do 16 years I can
believe a doctor is saying the word
people got victims of atrocity if if
October the 7th how can you say that so
what you tell me this what is a
proportionate response to 16 years
living in a cage no what is a
proportionate resp not a terror attack
what is it not a terror attack if they
if they just attacked IDF I've asked
many times what is proportion accept
that so you're saying just just to
attack the IDF would have been
acceptable I personally do not believe
I'm answering this let me answer your
question I'm going to say this be able
to agree AE I think the strategy at the
moment let me answer the question let me
answer the question let me answer the
question no if they had just military
targets acceptable my view of what
they're doing is I don't think it's
going to work I don't think the IDF is
going to eradicate Hamas and if that is
the mission stable and in the process
they killed tens of thousands of
innocent men women and children if they
do that I think they will radicalize an
entire new generation and make it worse
that's my view of what I'm now
witnessing but let me come back to
that's why that's why when we talk about
a military intervention actually happed
we want but doctor what happened October
7th wasn't a military intervention it
was a terror attack what we want as a
military you don't even think it
happened do you what we want is a
military intervention from Muslim armies
to re rescue a beleaguered people and
replace an people have to be given the
same human rights you do respect they
have to be given no no I will interrupt
me it's not your show you don't just
talk forever right what's the point of
asking I'm going to tell you what I
think about the Palestinian plight which
I've talked about many times you've
obviously missed it I think they should
be given the same human rights as
everybody else and particularly the same
rights of Israelis I think it's been a
75 year conflict with conflict a conf
conflict where people have been driven
out of their home 750,000 people in
wrong that was wrong encroaching on the
West Bank more and more and more that
was wrong so have been all the wars laed
against Israel that's been wrong all of
it is wrong right the history shows this
is a conflict riddled with wrongs on
both sides the 7th of October no it
didn't I never said it did well you seem
to you don't even think it happened
whole framing of your debate you don't
even think it happened I do think it
happened oh you did it diden 1200 people
were massacred were I think 1200 people
were killed were they massacred yeah
they were killed by terrorists they were
killed by people who were resisting an
occupation buit they're terrorists yeah
well that's your view it is my view and
by the way it's a view of any any person
who is is not Israeli or Palestinian
right any I disagree with that I
disagree with that one man have you not
heard the one man's terrorist is a n
man's Freedom Fighter have you never
heard that have you never heard
that let let me just play I want to just
read you this in May 2023 lukar MIM
who's a prominent member of your
organization called for an end to the
secular orders so that quotes the UK
will no longer be able to pump its
liberal filth its LGBT filth it's
feminist filth Into the Heart of the
Muslim world do you agree with him I
agree that the West is pumping secular
democracy into the Muslim world and I
LGBT fil I agree that actually what we
want to see in the Muslim world is a
system with an accountable government
right an elected
leader upholding Family Values right we
want to see an economic system where
wealth is circulated you equal rights
for gay people I believe I believe that
actually the the Islamic standard of law
should be the standard of law in the
country in obviously that's the standard
I believe in and I believe just to
clarify believe what is your view of
homosexuality I believe homosexuality is
a sin don't sin right so when gay people
come to your your practice do you treat
them oh of course why because I treat
all my patients with kindness and
without you tell them you think what
they do is a sin what an absurd thing to
say why why wouldn't you be say that why
would I that because they don't come why
don't you try going back to your surgery
tomorrow to why don't you go to your
surgery tomorrow and say before we go
any further to your patients I want you
to know what I think I think that I
agree with the guy who said that the
this country is full of LGBT filth
feminist understand I don't think Hamas
are a terror group I don't think what
they did in October the 7 was a terror
attack and by the way do you want me now
to treat you do you want do you
understand what I don't understand any
of that professional Integrity is you
understand you think that's professional
Integrity no I think professional
Integrity is treating the people I treat
with respect and with kindness how do
fairness well they know I do do they oh
yeah do they oh yeah do they know you
think they're filth I didn't say that
they're filth you you agreed with what
he said I didn't agree with what he said
you said I agree no I agree pay the tap
back in your life I agree with the fact
that the Muslim World should have the
Islamic system yeah I didn't say I agree
with I don't use words you want full
Sharia law for this country for this
country I'm working for our group works
for Islam the restoration of Islam in
the Muslim world what about here we work
we work up hold Islamic values in our
personal life and in the Muslim
Community do you want sh law here or no
I would love you know what you'd love it
no I tell you what that in this last two
months one of the strangest things has
been where people here have been looking
at the people in Gaza and they've been
going and looking and reading the Quran
and they've been looking at it and I'd
invite you and your audience to do that
CL do that and cl you would like law
here and they are not convinced by these
neocon
neocon caricatures of Islam are they
actually I don't think people all I've
done is ask you straightforward question
you've revealed your beliefs in the
answers yeah you have I I you may not
even realize what you've done but you
have I believe in Islamic law and I
don't believe in the caricature that you
try and present of Islam would you like
Sharia law in this country I would love
to see I would love to see you want
Sharia law in this country I don't want
Sharia law in this country well that's
your wish but you would yeah but I no I
I would you I believe it's the I believe
it's the best system but I'm not work
I'm not working like it in this country
I would I'm not working I believe in
Islamic you know you know the Islamic
civilization was the only civiliz quick
to answer everything else yes or no
Islamic civilization was the only
civilization that brought peace to the
Middle East for Muslims Jews and
Christians I would love to see that
system there wouldn't you like to see a
system who pays who pays your salary
wouldn't you like to see a system where
Muslims Jews and Christians would live
country to live undera law it's not
talking about this middle I'm talking
about Middle East but you suggested you
wanted it to be law here you suggest do
you or not you you do you or not what's
what's funny what's funny is your
approach of question why just answer the
question because you know why it's funny
yes or no you either do or you don't
right I ask a question the answer is yes
or no why can't you say yes or no I
believe in the Islamic system would you
like Shia law in this country I would
love yes or no I would love to see you
want no no answer the question never
mind what I want what do you want I want
to see is this Islamic system reest
would you like Sharia law in this
country last time I'm going to ask if
Sharia law if Sharia law if Sharia law
means upholding Family Values means
looking after the poor means no gays no
feminist are women who get above
themselves your caricature no that's oh
I know what sh law wants why do why does
so many women become Muslim these days
why do want is that what you're going to
tell me no no why why does so manyl they
want to be oppressed women in the world
become Muslim these days you tell me I
don't you better ask them what don't you
tell me what you think they they seem to
find it something that attracts them
Islam really yeah okay many many many
women in the west become Muslim and for
some reason they seem to like the fact
that it's do you work with women doctors
yes I do how how do they feel about your
views on this I keep a very strict
professional line between my they know
where your views are when they watch
this they're they're going to be
surprised some of them will know some of
them will not know some of them will
know some of them will not know okay
doctor thank you for coming in I
appreciate it um you've been
enlightening with your responses you may
not realize quite how enlightening but
you might find out when you see the
reaction but I appreciate you coming in
thank you you're
welcome